more and more shark sightings are taking  place up in Cape Cod in Massachusetts  this is a video of a recent sighting  that everybody is talking about this is  to get out yeah now I'm I'm that's an  amazing huge shark a shark and  everybody's talking about it but I'm  from Boston and I know that a lot of  people that's sad I know that a lot of  people from Boston spend time on Cape  Cod and that's why I was wondering in  that clip where's the Boston accents I  saw that clip and I'm like that's not  right that seemed right to me here's  what I was expecting that video to sound  like oh my God look at that shocked  Barney daddy's a large shark darn wicked  huge Donnie that thing could eat us for  supper it's bigger than chrome for all  this thing's bigger than Larry  I wanted it to be